hätten sie vorbehalte wenn heute ein
schwuler bundeskanzler würde
nein wer für sie völlig normal also ich
sage über über die frage der sexuellen
orientierung
das geht die öffentlichkeit nichts an
solange sich das im rahmen der gesetze
bewegt und so lange es nicht kinder
betrifft an der stelle ist für mich
allerdings eine absolute grenze erreicht
ist das kein thema für die öffentliche
diskussion aber schwuler bundeskanzler
habe überhaupt kein thema für mich
ich musste das wirklich zwei mal gucken
weil ich erschrocken war über diese
antwort und natürlich kann man da ganz
kurz antworten und sagen natürlich kann
ein schwuler kanzler sein das ist glaube
ich in der heutigen zeit überhaupt kein
problem und das sollte gar keine debatte
seien aber dass dann noch hinterher
geschoben werden muss mit kindern sollte
da aber nicht sein also das zeigt ja
auch so wie ganz spontan gedanken durch
den kopf von herrn merz schießen
und da war ich schon geschockt und ganz
ehrlich da muss er sich für
entschuldigen dass gewöhnen sich ohnehin
im augenblick relativ viele menschen
daran
ein leben ohne arbeit zu führen das ist
in der krise richtig nur ich habe diese
woche in einem hotel übernachtet wo
praktisch überhaupt kein personal mehr
vorhanden war
also wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir uns nicht alle daran gewöhnen
dass wir ohne arbeit leben können wir
müssen zurück an die arbeit
wir sind in einer schweren pandemie die
sich in vielen wirtschaftsbereichen noch
sehr krass gerade auswirkt und die leute
sitzen ja nicht zu hause weil sie zu
hause sitzen wollen oder weil sie sagen
wir nehmen uns jetzt mal urlaub sondern
wir sitzen da weil wir teilweise
drastische einbrüche in
wirtschaftsbereichen haben weil das alle
umtreibt bei menschen angst um ihr
unternehmen oder angst um ihre
arbeitsplätze haben und da so zu tun als
ob kassierung wie man ein bisschen
urlaub sei für die leute und sich
niemand da gefälligst an gebühren soll
auch das zeigt er dass herr merz darf
von oben herab unterwegs ist und ich bin
wirklich gespannt welches denken sich in
der union durchsetzen wird nach angela
merkel hier ist mir von der bild zeitung
der friedrich merz wird für eine aussage
kritisiert gestern abend weil die
richtigen fragen
er sagte ihm sei egal welche sexuelle
orientierung jemand habe so lange
im rahmen der gesetze und nicht in
kontakt mit kindern angesprochen auf die
frage ob ihn ein homosexueller
bundeskanzler okay wäre was löst das bei
ihnen aus so eine aussage von
parteikollegen
naja wenn die erste assoziation bei
homosexualität gesetzes fragen oder
pädophilie ist dann müssen sie sich eher
fragen an friedrich merz richten würde
ich sagen ja ja sie haben sich auf die
äußerungen von friedrich merz bei
twitter zu wort gemeldet und haben gegen
vorgeworfen keine ahnung zu haben oder
möglicherweise sozial zynisch zu sein
oder beides was hat sie denn so wütend
gemacht
kurzarbeit ist so wenn die stabilste
brücke über ein tiefes wirtschaftliches
tal
das hilft arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmern
in den familien stück sicherheit zu
haben keine angst zu haben es hilft
allen dingen aber unternehmen und ich
finde dass man auf praktika werden muss
und nicht von der seitenlinie
irgendwelche altklugen bemerkung ein
schmeißen darf das thema ist viel zu
ernst wir haben die größte
wirtschaftskrise in unserer generation
und alle experten international erkennen
dass an dass kurzarbeit hilft
beschäftigung zu sichern damit die
wirtschaft auch wieder durchstarten kann
das eine frage der ökonomischen vernunft
und auch der sozialen sicherheit könnten
sie sich denn vorstellen gemeinsam mit
einer cdu unter der führung von
friedrich merz zu regieren
die davon aus diese frage wird sich
nicht stellen tatsache ist wir regieren
und es ist gut dass wir in diesen zeiten
verantwortung übernehmen dass wir mit
dem konjunkturpaket von olaf scholz die
wirtschaft ankurbeln dass wir mit
kurzarbeit brücken über dieses tiefe
wirtschaftliche teil bauen wir brauchen
eine balance zwischen wirtschaftlicher
vernunft und sozialer sicherheit genau
dafür stehen wir ein anderes foto vom
wochenende sie haben gerade die stadien
schon angesprochen können sie erklären
warum man in der loge beim fc bayern
münchen eng beieinander sitzt aber
stattdessen ganz streng in der fankurve
die regeln einhält
nein absolut nicht
und ich muss sagen als ich das bild
gesehen aber er hat freunde was ist denn
mit euch los ich kann es nicht erklären
der deutsche fußball-bund hat regeln und
die damen und herren halten sich nicht
an dieses übermut oder ist das so eine
wir sehen das ja auch auf von vielen
oder von manchen politikern in anderen
ländern also äußern sich tagsüber zu den
chor ohne regeln und gehen abends den
privaten mit vielen leuten feiern
all diese fälle gab es schon geht dann
manchmal ja für für mich muss das nicht
gelten oder ich kriege das ist nicht das
ist jetzt überhaupt mache ich mit liefer
borussia dortmund das hat damit gar
nichts zu tun ich würde sagen wenn es
völlig anders wäre aber was ich da
gesehen habe spontan meine mein gedanke
dummheit oder arroganz ich würde sagen
peter thoma noch arroganz aber ich muss
ihm vielleicht etwas erklären was er gar
nicht wissen konnte der mann der bei uns
im stadion für diese zuteilung die wie
immer muss sich auch korrekt aber sagen
der wir immer folge geleistet sind hat
die auf grund der bayrischen
infektionsschutz verordnung aufgeteilt
in dem man da in dem es ja ist es dürfen
zehn mann zusammenhocken das ist geht's
winziges hier in die kneipe gehen in
bayern dürfen sie das auch zehn leute
zumindest mal das ist zum wochenende
hatte das bestand dürfen sie das machen
ich glaube ganz einfach es hat hier ein
nennen wir es mal interpretations
missverständnis gegeben wir haben zu
keinem zeitpunkt irgendein provozieren
wollen bitte um entschuldigung das bild
ist in der öffentlichkeit nicht optimal
gewesen aber wir wollten weder
irgendetwas provozieren noch haben wir
das aus dummheit gemacht sondern wir
haben einfach diese mitteilung des
gesundheitsamtes münchens so
interpretiert dass eben für uns an
diesem spieltag die bayerische
verordnung im gültigkeit hat